uh what's really really funny is as
Millennials are entering leadership
positions they're complaining about
Millennials uh they're also complaining
about gen Z it's just really funny I
just appreciate the irony so much
um but yes of course there are cultural
shifts Society companies are living
breathing organisms that necessarily
have to change with changing tastes
changing politics changing technology
younger Generations now are the most
inclusive generation you know they don't
care where you're from what the color of
your skin is they don't care what your
gender identity is what your sexuality
is they understand that gender and
sexuality are different things for them
it's a big nothing they're just a very
inclusive generation and it puts a lot
of pressure in organizations because
this Young Generation expects that that
other organizations are as inclusive as
they are and they are perplexed when
those organizations are not so yes I
think that's one example of young
Generations exerting positive pressure
on the changing culture of companies and
there are others of course